how do we calculate the square root of a
non-perfect square
for example what is the square root of
it's very simple to calculate the
approximate square root of 46.
first let's look at its nearest square
the nearest square of 46 is 49. then we
write square root of 49
here we need to add one fraction
in the numerator we write 46 minus 49
and this difference is very important
in the denominator we write 2 multiplied
by the square root of the nearest square
which is square root of 49
and the square root of 49 is 7 so here
the numerator will be negative 3 and the
denominator will have 2 multiplied by 7.
by solving 7 minus 3 over 14 we get this
answer and if you find the answer using
the calculator you will get 6.7823
approximately
so it's very easy to solve using this
formula
the square root of a non-perfect square
is approximately equal to the square
root of the nearest perfect square plus
the deviation divided by 2 multiplied by
the square root of the nearest perfect
square using the same trick can you tell
me the square root of 164 the answer for
this will be shown in our next video
we just got acquired by infinity learn
and we wanted to share the happiness
with you
for a limited period we have an
unbelievable offer for you
do check out the links in the
description and the first comment below